roll oh hello my name's Adam Smith I'm
calling from nobelprize.org the website
of the Nobel Prize in Stockholm many
congratulations on their waters and well
thank you where where am i calling you
you're in Maine I
you've reached me where I've lived for
many years in the middle of nowhere
Maine wrong Maine you know also known as
central Maine in the extreme northeast
of this great country of ours sounds a
beautiful place to be located it is
physically beautiful including I'm
looking out the window it's very
beautiful day today which it often is
full colors in the light not quite yet
but it's still green as can be but it's
because Maine is not like Arizona
you're being awarded today so unraveling
the mechanisms of the circadian rhythm
yes correct that that was about half of
our work during my time when I was
employed had to do with circadian
rhythms indeed that became amongst our
most well known research achievements if
any usually and relentlessly caught her
with rasa she's already spoken so he and
I joined forces in the early mid 80s and
imagined that we liked or we might not
education me go homeward and upward
doing research together mentor reading
which often involved crucially what I
call a eyes actual investigators like
students postdoctoral supervisees from
the two labs working very closely
together even day by day so that was
enjoyable we it wasn't that either lab
was way out on its own limb we had a lot
of mutual support
I think it's further so you know
obviously had had a very special working
relationship there was something magical
about the team this was based in large
part on becoming close personally at the
beginning where our research interest in
very general terms were in genetics writ
large
it was only after six seven or eight
years that we started to work things
together and imagined that possibly our
backgrounds and our wood skills if any
might be complementary the key reason
that we got into that kind of
relationship because we were personally
close we had mutual interest in low
culture stuff like sports and
rock'n'roll music and beautiful
substances and stuff and so we spent a
lot of time just carousing or sitting
together in misery at local sports
stadium we have also certain many
similar interests even in the pre rhythm
research games he is a molecular
geneticist I as a straight up fruit fly
geneticist yeah and that brings us on to
flies what we should say a word for
flies on this day of all days because
once again the power of the fly as a
model organism has right this is
something I've always I I was taught
when I was a graduate student about what
a phrase is known as the lore of
Drosophila to know about the deep
history going way all the way back in
the nineteen twenties and the forties
and the 90s and now the second decade of
the current century it's just one of
million examples of how basic research
on a supposedly irrelevant organism can
have have broader significance than then
with regard to what's going on in terms
of that organism itself and this has
been true Alfred Father shows which has
been a major contributor for decades for
well over a century actually well that's
dedicate this day to this life yeah this
that the key fourth awardee here is
though is that some of us call them the
little slides
so the little flies deserve another tip
of the hat i think that's lovely terms
of what has happened today indeed indeed
they do and it's been such a pleasure
speaking to you i'm very much looking
forward to meeting you will you be
coming to Stockholm in December yeah yes
I well I think I almost have to but I'm
willing to good I was in Sweden once in
my time back at the time when Swedish
folk drove on the left-hand side of the
roadway so I'm looking forward to going
back to Stockholm where I once was in
1967 very much look forward to meeting
you thank you